- I'm just making you look like
a long-lost member of My Chemical Romance.
You just went through some hard times.
(upbeat orchestral music)
I have never done men's hair before.
I don't really have any men in my life
that need their hair done by me.
- I feel like it's gonna be easier
'cause there's less of it.
- How hard could it be?
I have 10 times the hair that you have.
- We're gonna find out how hard it is
to do guys' hair.
- No.
- The rules are no cutting
allowed, and no dying allowed.
But everything else is fair game.
- Today for your hair, I'm
going for just woke up,
kind curly.
- So like in K-dramas when
like those people wake up,
they look flawless.
- Yes!
- Without anything.
- The most majestic, beautiful creature
that I know is a peacock.
I'm gonna like stand it up in the back,
hopefully have some glitter.
- I'm gonna try a braid.
If I can't, maybe I'll
part it in the middle.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- At least your hair will smell good.
Not so much like look great.
- 'Cause that's what every guy wants,
hair that just smells good.
- My hair's really not hard to play with.
- I'm gonna crank this up to 450 degrees.
- 450 degrees, is that even legal?
- Oh it looks kinda cool from the back.
- Can you see it from the front?
- I don't know if I can
do it from the front.
- This is more complicated
than I anticipated.
- It's very close to my face.
(laughs)
It's making smoke!
- That's the product burning off.
- That's supposed to happen, making sure.
- Braid is a cool look, but
you can't see it as much.
Of course I feel like this
is a look.
- Loud and proud.
- You step into the clurb, and
you're like I have arrived!
- When I go clurbing.
- Yeah.
- Oh, oh, oh, you can't clurb that hard.
- You're like that character
from Dragon Ball Z right now.
- If she gave me Goku hair today,
I'd be pretty okay with that.
- I'm hearing this noise,
my hair is pulling out.
- What, no!
(laughs)
I don't think so.
- It's not really standing up, though.
'Cause you have heavy hair.
Men's hair, heavier than you think.
- You really are starting to look like
a K-drama star, though.
It's kinda creeping me out.
- I don't think this would even make
a really good Halloween look.
- It would, if you were
dressing up like a peacock.
- I've always been like so
intrigued by men's products,
like these gels and these waxes.
They're quite elaborate.
- I'm actually excited
to find out that my hair can do this.
(groaning)
(laughing)
- Woah!
- Do I look like a poodle?
What is happening to my hair?
- His hair is quite heavy and thick.
They just kinda all fall down.
- I see green.
- Okay, so guys' hair
is a little bit weirder
than I anticipated.
You have to like be so
specific with each bit.
- And then I'm just
gonna gather these bits,
'cause why not.
You look like a cute troll.
- Oh.
(laughs)
- Do you see the amount
of glitter falling?
(laughs)
- Holy crap!
- God, men's products are quite difficult.
I have a lot of respect for men now.
- Okay, I think it's done.
- Is it done?
- Alright, are you ready to see?
- Can I see the mirror?
(upbeat whistling music)
(laughing)
- You look great.
- Okay, I'm not hating, for sure.
- What the hell is that?
(laughs)
- This is not a good look
to walk down the street.
- But a good look for a concert.
- But, yeah.
- I've never seen my
hair like this, curled.
- You look dapper, man.
- 'Cause I have like,
the straightest hair possible.
- You have some really straight hair.
- Even when you think a guy has long hair,
their hair is a lot less manageable.
- My biggest difficulty with
this project was his attitude.
He was just not open.